this is a production of Cornell
University
welcome everybody today it's a real
pleasure to be back here I haven't been
back to Cornell in a few years even
though New York City's not really that
far away so thank you so much for
inviting me here to talk about the
sustainable sites initiative which is a
project that I've been involved with now
for almost eight years and it's a
project that I got started with my
involvement with through Cornell through
working with dr. Nina basak and the
sustainable sites team to develop
sustainable protocols for landscapes and
so today I'm going to discuss what the
guidelines are all about and go through
some of the principles behind the
guidelines I'm going to discuss the
process through which we've come through
in about the last 10 years total to get
to where we are today with the guideline
and rating system then i'm going to give
some examples of credits that probably
relate to some of the work you may be
doing relating to vegetation and soil
specifically even though the system is
involves much more than just that but
i'll focus a little bit on that today
and then i'll also give some site
specific examples of projects that were
involved in the pilot or testing process
for the system within the last few years
and then also i'll go into what's next
since there's more to come from this
project so as i mentioned i first got
involved with this project as a as a
graduate student and i was lucky enough
to get hired on to be a research
assistant specifically in the vegetation
subcommittees and with a little bit of
work also in the human health and
well-being and even the soil
subcommittees also Fred cow it and I
don't know if Fred's here today did a
lot of work on this project over the
years in the soil sections
believe is also a reviewer in many of
the pilot studies for this project so
anybody who has more questions about
sustainable sites after I've gone and
especially about soil I would recommend
you talk to Fred and then also Nina
Basak as well who unfortunately couldn't
be here today because she's at an oak
conference so so sustainable sites is
essentially a set of guidelines in a
voluntary rating system for sustainable
landscape design construction and
maintenance and this came out of the
growth of green building which over the
past decade and a half has had
tremendous impact on that construction
design and then facilities maintenance
professions overall not just throughout
America but globally and so this is the
very first LEED Platinum building in in
America and so it was really forward
thinking at the time but one of the
troubling things was that when you
looked at landscapes and early versions
of lead there was a paltry amount of
direction and really not a lot of great
critical thinking involving what
sustainable landscapes really meant in
relation to the building side of things
and so you know even though we know that
buildings are really important and how
we direct our resources in how we
construct them and manage them it's
really important there's a lot more than
just that in the world there's a lot
more than just buildings thank goodness
so the the team on sites came together
and essentially the team that first came
together to discuss some of the other
issues with sustainable development
which include you know pesticide use you
know water usage invasive species
problems combined sewer overflow issues
and how we manage our stormwater urban
heat island affects climate change
erosion problems these were all issues
that we didn't think we're being very
well managed through the lead or the US
Green Building Council sustainability
criteria so with that the Lady Bird
Johnson Wildflower Center through
University of Texas at Austin the US
Green Building Council and the American
Society of landscape architects all came
together and sort of all simultaneously
had the same idea that they really
needed to about to develop a rating
system that partnered with lead or US
Green Building Council guidelines and
helped to get those a little more on
track with the best scientific knowledge
that they could put together and the
best team that they could put together
to try to move forward with a
comprehensive set of ratings and a
system to help put a better spin on what
sustainable design meant in terms of
landscapes so with that the goals of
sites have been and continue to be to
create regenerative systems into foster
resiliency to ensure future resource
supply and demitted gate climate change
to enhance human wellbeing and
strengthen community so there's
community components to this as well to
also transform the market through design
development and maintenance practices
and so I'm involved a lot in capital
projects in my current role and I've
seen over the past several years how
sustainable development guidelines such
as lead have really transformed the
industry and so what was once really
difficult to conceive of has over time
through the work of these types of
rating systems driven it to become more
of an industry standards so well the
green building side of things is really
well on its way with lead and some other
sustainability systems like that the
landscape side is still a little bit
nascent as far as how we're going to
follow up with industry standards and to
generate that further so
ok so the principles behind sustainable
sites are based on ecosystem services
which are benefits that people obtain
from ecosystems that support our lives
but are unfortunately often considered
free and are not often part of
traditional accounting methods so this
whole system is underpinned by bringing
forward of some of these things that we
haven't always thought of as formerly
and as far as cost benefits are
concerned and so these are just a few of
the ecosystem services that were
actually considered in the development
of the entire rating system and we're
going forward and trying to build
systems that are a lot more thoughtful
and so this could be the results when
you it's just an example of a successful
credential pilot project that's been
certified recently and so you can see
there's quite a difference between that
original LEED Platinum building that I
showed where there was like a couple of
token trees in the front braces versus a
much more sophisticated landscape that
takes into account a lot of the other
ecosystem services that were not here to
for really thought of formally so some
of the other principles behind sites
include the fact that we believe that
almost any type of landscape could be
developed in this manner so the testing
has been very thoughtfully positioned so
that even if you have a really small
site you should be able to do this
whether you have a really hyper urban
site you should also be able to take the
system and apply the principles or if
you have a pristine green site that's
you know maybe even high quality natural
areas that you should also be able to
apply these principles there too and so
also with the idea that ecosystem
services can be derived with any
landscape theory so the timeline of
sites goes way back to 2005 so 10 years
now and so through time we've gone
through research and development of
developing standards and guidelines and
then performance benchmarks were in
which were in draft form in
2008-2009 which is what I was involved
with early on and helping to create and
edit some of those then they ran a pilot
program between 2010 and 2012 and I also
was involved with a pilot project in
Canada when in my formal role at Humber
Arboretum in Toronto and so I've got
pilot program experience as well and I
can tell you a little bit more about
that later then also beyond that they've
been working with all the data that's
come through the pilot project and been
refining it since there were obviously
lots of criticisms and lots of
challenges that we were able to look at
from the pilot process that were then
taken went back through and then tried
to clean up the process to make it
easier more accessible and hopefully
less expensive also to to manage and so
now the latest rendition of sustainable
sites is actually in v2 and I have a
copy of the guidelines here so it's
quite large but you can get this online
if you'd like and so this is the latest
version of the guidelines and rating
systems and what's great is just this
past June it's been formally announced
that the US Green Building Council and
GBC I which is the credentialing and
accreditation body for lead is formally
taking the system on so it's now
officially part of the lead suite of
systems and this is the first time ever
that the US Green Building Council has
adopted a program that they didn't
specifically develop themselves so it's
quite an achievement and the system has
been I guess designed to mesh from the
very GetGo but it's taken quite a lot of
work to get that to come to fruition and
so finally you can become you can have a
site that's accredited officially and
will be credentialed through GBC I so
with the three reports that have been
released today this was the first one
that you can look this up and see how
everything was based initially then
there's also been some great support
through the US government and so an
example of the way that this
particular system is influencing not
just industry standards but also in
influencing government policy is that
the US government's been adopting the
guidelines also for their own sites
since the government owns quite a lot of
acreage throughout the country so it can
be very influential just to have a
government agree that these are their de
facto guidelines that they're going to
use going forward so that's actually
happening and so beyond that I'll
explain the sites program goals for the
pilot program because it's been it's
been very interesting to see a lot of
different kinds of sites go through the
pilot process and get we were able to
derive a lot of great information to
refine the process through the pilot
programs so we really were looking to
gain feedback and revise the credits
from the get-go since we knew that this
is quite a complex system and so we've
been always knowing that it's not going
to be really ever finished for quite
some time so the pilot program started
in 2010 and these are the kinds of
projects that project types so there was
a good diversity deliberately in the
pilot project celeste selection process
between types of spaces so it ranges
between open space and institutional
commercial residential government
project sizes also tried to have a
diversity of really small sites and even
very large sites so some of the sites
that were in the pilot project were well
over 500 acres which is quite large and
then also a different mix of existing
uses so the way we define oh yeah okay
so the way we define what sorry I want
to go back here gray field greenfield
and brownfield grey field is a
previously developed site but not one
that is completely toxic green field is
something that's not really been that
affected by development so a natural
area might be considered a green field
but a park depending on the
original usage could be as well and then
there's brown fields which are seriously
toxic sites which actually need some
sort of remediation even extra thought
and process to be able to make use of
them and to get them to be regenerative
again so there's 47 sites to date that
were certified by the pilot projects and
the pilot project process is now closed
and so there were originally I think
maybe close to 200 sites that applied to
be pilot projects and so these were the
sites that across the country actually
finished the process and actually got
certification so I mentioned that I was
involved with a pilot project in Canada
and we did not achieve certification and
so it is as much telling what sights did
not achieve certification as it is which
ones did and so though I was sad that we
didn't achieve certification one of the
challenges that we had and one thing
that I deliberately went into with my
eyes wide open is that I was trying to
certify a site that had been completed
primarily over five years before so the
message that I got and that went back to
the site's team was that you should not
really try to be cribbed getting
certified for this particular
sustainable sites of certification
process unless you've got a very new
project coming online and you're able to
start the process for sustainable sites
in early in the concept stage so I was
trying to do it on the back end and I
really couldn't get all the data
together in order to do that from what
the site looked like prior to the
project so those were words of caution
that I had to bring back to the site's
team and they took that and I think now
they know that now so that's just one
example of how you know you might fail
if you're doing a pilot project and
that's okay too we went pretty far down
the process so so as I mentioned we got
47 sites certified and a very good mix
of different project types and that was
absolutely deliberate and so got great
data from that but what was really an
early-stage criticism of the sustainable
sites initiative was whether or not you
could do it for a really really small
site and we did have some some sites
that were able to prove that
yes you can do this and for instance you
could actually apply these principles to
a backyard landscape like a urban
postage stamp landscape and still do
that if you'd like but it is a little
bit easier perhaps if you have a larger
scale to work with it is and I was going
to talk about that at the end as an
example so yes there is a pilot project
site here that did achieve certification
and it is the entry gardens to man
library so I yes and I have some good
some good stats on that too so
interesting also to look at what pilot
projects how they were able to go
through and what level of certification
so at the time of the pilot projects we
had a star system so the more stars you
got the higher the level of
certification so four stars would be
equivalent to flatland platinum and one
star would be equivalent ty guess is it
bronze or gets Bronze Silver Gold and
Platinum I think for lead so these were
the approximate equivalencies but you
can see here that the vast majority of
the projects went for the one star
certification which is a little bit
easier to do the hardest obviously the
four stars and I believe that was the
Phipps conservatory in Pittsburgh and so
anybody who's gone to the Phipps
conservatory can check out that site
they are tremendous in their leadership
in sustainability and in fact they were
able to get certified triple
certification in LEED Platinum for their
building Living Building Challenge
certification with all or nothing and
then level of certification for
sustainable sites so they are really an
exemplary an exemplary project to look
at so now we've got the sites version 2
rating system and then we also have
reference guide so these are available
online and so within the new rating
system there is a division in different
guidelines and credits that follow in
line basically following the general
design process that when you're going
through a new project if you you've got
your landscape architect your design
team your
Engineers in place and your contractors
hired it takes it from pre design site
and concept through to planning
different aspects from water management
soil vegetation of your materials usage
your your reuse of materials hopefully
as well then also guides each your human
health and well-being and how to plan
for your community or just general usage
of the site to optimal effect then going
into construction and then operations
and maintenance guidelines since we all
know that a project doesn't end when the
construction is over we also have to
operate and keep our sites working
functionally and so that's an extra
challenge even beyond what was normally
taken into account with the buildings
because all of this entails stewarding
functional living landscapes so a
building can theoretically be a little
bit more stagnant than a landscape pen
but a landscape was always going to be
changing and it's always going to
hopefully be growing in some way as well
so managing that over time is actually
much more challenging I would argue them
then opening a building and maintaining
a building although I manage facilities
and horticulture in my current job so I
know too that buildings break down and
they're difficult to do as well so I
don't want to I don't want to say that
it's not easy that's not hard for both
things but I think managing landscapes
and thinking about this long term is
even much more difficult for for these
kinds of systems and then beyond that
there's also credits and guidelines for
how to go forth with extra extra work
that you can do for education and
monitoring the performance over time of
these landscapes and then even extra
innovation and exemplary performance
credit since these projects have been
tremendous in coming back with to us
with all sorts of really innovative
things that we had never thought of
before so always looking to steward that
so there's a scorecard that looks kind
of similar to what you might find if you
run through a lead project and
this is what it looks like I'm not you
can look at this online it's a lot of
small print but you get the picture you
can kind of do your little checklist
ahead of time and then through the
process and see how you're scoring so
it's also interesting to look at the
kinds of professionals who have been
reporting to us that they're most
interested in this project and so
obviously you can see that landscape
architects have been the majority
interest in this project and that's
that's reflective obviously is the fact
that they're the ones who really
involved with with the I guess design
and construction process and a lot of
these projects but there's a lot of
other professions that fish so be
affecting and hopefully stewarding new
professional I guess interest in
sustainability and so I know I'm a
horticulturist by training and I found
working through this process to be
invaluable and I think because of it I'm
hopefully a better partner in the
construction process when I get involved
with that and so I think there there's a
lot to be learned for a whole slew of
different professions here so the system
is based on a 200 point scale at this
point and it recognizes percentage of
attainment there's actually a teen
prerequisites so those are not just
credits those are things that you
absolutely must do in order to be a part
of the system and so I'll explain a few
of those going forward but beyond the 18
prerequisites there's also many points
and then some of the points are awarded
for different credits based on level of
attainment as well and so there's now
four levels of attainment that are well
approximate now the lead system so now
we're going more into the platinum and
the gold certification I believe in
order to make it mesh better with the
lead system so alleble eligible projects
could be a new construction that may gee
maybe
major renovations as well but this is
really a system designed for brand new
projects and as I mentioned it's really
difficult to try to do it after the fact
so I don't recommend it myself there's
no maximum size but there is a minimum
of two thousand square feet in order to
to be involved and we're open to all
projects types with sites with buildings
are without so that was the other
interesting comparison to lead early on
if you didn't have a building on your
site you couldn't get LEED certification
and so you know what there's a lot more
than just buildings so we felt it was
important that you didn't have to hang
your hat on a building in order to be
considered a sustainable site and then
this is also open globally as well so
there were some initial pilot projects
that applied to be a part of the the
testing process and including my own
which was in canada and i think if you
and australia so i'm not sure if any of
those actually finished i think there
was a few extra challenges that comes
from trying to work on this project from
outside the country but that's something
i know they're going to be working on
and the Green Building Council has the
capacity to bring it forward and to a
global scale so the principles behind
the process involve an examination of
your waste hierarchy and so ultimately
we try to prevent waste if we can't do
that we reduce it then if we can't do
that we just reuse and then recycle and
then the ultimate worst thing that we
can do is really to have things that are
disposed so we try to avoid that so we
try to stay to the top of the waste
hierarchy with the system credits and
then we're also trying to instill a
paradigm shift from not just
conservation but regeneration so I'll
show some examples of projects that were
went beyond just conserving high-value
landscapes but also took pretty
dysfunctional landscapes and then made
them into regenerative
so this this graphic shows further the
the difference between conservation and
then bringing it over to regeneration so
if you have a well-performing landscape
you could in theory conserve what you
have and just get really good tree
protection or protect that site you know
putting a fence around it is just an
example of that and then you're going to
come out you know okay just conservation
is very important and we're trying to
Stewart that in the process or you could
manage a little bit better what you've
got if you're not doing such a good job
of that restoration you know if you cut
your tree down maybe you can try to
restore the landscape and then get it
back up to a functional level and then
of course there's lots of sites that
we're working with that are toxic
there's like hardly any life in them
right now and the existing conditions
are deplorable so sites are really
encouraged to take on those kinds of
challenges in the process and to develop
a project that's going to create future
site conditions that are that are much
much better and have regenerative and
functional landscapes in the future so i
said i was going to focus a little bit
on soil and vegetation credit since i
think that probably best applies to most
of this this group here and so a lot of
the credits you can see listed here of
pertain to that there's four at the top
that are actually required and so that's
what i mentioned before the prerequisite
so you can see here that you have no you
have no recourse but to create and
communicate a soil management plan we
must see that in order for you to be
considered part of the system for
sustainable sites you have to agree to
control and manage your invasive species
and you have to use appropriate plans
and so it's interesting how we define
all this but we've debated a lot over
that but everybody on the team felt that
it was imperative that we at least start
with that as a baseline and so the rest
of the credits are actually optional and
so there's different levels of points
that you can get depending on
how you can go through the process so
some examples include controlling and
manage invasive plants as I mentioned we
just thought this is not even an option
and so you can see here I think this is
kudzu so we just don't even want to talk
about why anymore it's like just do it
just control and manage and deal with
invasive species if you're developing a
new site and don't add new invasive
species into your project either so
that's also something that's very
important and that gets vetted through
the system and so i don't know i think
i'd probably be preaching to the choir
to even go further into why this is
important so i think i'll just move on
but you can talk to me afterwards if you
want to discuss that further using
appropriate plants this was something
that went over a lot of debate and I
know Nina was involved a lot in this
discussion too we are trying to a
steward not native plants necessarily
but just appropriate plants so as long
as they're not invasive and they're
appropriate for the site then that's
fine so you could theoretically get
sustainable sites accreditation without
having any native plants on your site if
you so chose there are definitely some
credits that encourage native plants and
responsible use of native plants but
it's not always the most appropriate to
to be you know only using native plants
so that's not what this is all about
it's just making sure that they're
appropriate and that they're legally
source as well since our industry
sometimes has some issues with illegal
sourcing of plant material and you know
making sure that the nurseries are also
you know in line with that is really
important and using appropriate plants
if you're going for this kind of credit
you might just show a planting plan
similar to this and it's not really all
that complicated you know this is just
an example of one of the submissions for
for a project and you know it hopefully
isn't going to be too difficult to to
get this credit and just you know do the
checkoff list and make sure you're not
you're doing invasive species and you're
probably be okay also there's credits to
and prerequisites to conserve healthy
resources and so some of those include
mapping and making sure that you're on
top of your creation and management of
vegetation and soil protection zones so
it's always an uphill battle it seems
when you're dealing with construction to
make sure that you're protecting trees
or soil quality that that you've got on
your site that are existing that are
functional so this is a credit they're
actually this is a prerequisite sorry
that designates and communicates your
vegetation and soil protection zones at
the get-go so this is again not an
option you just have to do this and so
hopefully this should be best management
practice or proper practice for any
construction project but anybody who's
ever been involved with the project
knows that that's not always the obvious
thing and keeping on track with that it
can be really difficult so I know we
still struggle with this is broken
mechanic garden and it's something that
I'm always trying to make sure that the
specifications we do and with the
management of the projects that were on
top of it but it's so important so this
could be an example of you know
communicating where your vegetation and
self protection zones are going to be on
a project you know you would say oh I've
got prime farmland here I don't want to
run that all over with heavy equipment
and destroy the soil quality there I've
got existing native plant communities
let's not destroy those by driving
bulldozers all over it or parking our
trucks there then also a special status
vegetation so there's also some credits
in the system not just for high quality
native plant communities or farmland
soils but for
I guess heritage value specimen so
sometimes trees might not be native and
they but they might have some sort of
other value that is important for you to
preserve in the site so try not to
destroy all that during the the process
is really important there's also an
interesting credit that i wanted to
mention called optimize biomass and so
that is been debated quite a lot but
essentially here it's intended to help
you support the water nutrient
atmospheric gas and climate regulation
system on site by maintaining a sort of
ecological integrity for that site
that's comparable to what is in your
native plant communities there so well
that might sound a little complicated
what all it comes down to is really
determining what the terrestrial biomes
so what if you're in a desert community
don't try to plant a landscape that is
going to be approximate to what you
would have in the Northeast because
you're going to need so many more water
and nutrient inputs that it's not a very
sustainable landscape so and likewise
you know you might not want to try to
create a desert landscape and not expect
a lot of success with that if you're
trying to do that in a really rainy area
you know just be realistic and look at
what's around you and look at the
resources that will be coming into your
site naturally with precipitation
climate soils and and just look at that
and be realistic about that and so and
by that then you can sort of what what
you're doing there is optimizing your
biomass so similarly there's another
credit for reducing urban heat island
effect so how do we do that and how do
we calculate that well we look at the
area of Nan roof areas
then you know put in these numbers here
you know you got your nan roof measures
your area of high reflected roof so in
the credit it also takes into account
vegetated areas so you can vegetate your
roof and help to mitigate a little bit
urban heat island effect with that but
you can also just change the
reflectivity of the surfaces of your
site as well so there's options there's
options with that also we're looking to
use vegetation to minimize building
energies it's so this was a really
interesting credit that I worked a lot
on where we developed calculations to
try to prove whether your vegetation on
your roof or even around the building
was able to provide reduced energy
benefits to the building itself so by
that if you have a green roof you're
likely going to reduce your air
conditioning costs quite significantly
so we've got a calculator to help you
with that similarly if you plant certain
shade trees at a very specific distance
to your building then you can also
derive benefit from shading around and
outside your building that are going to
reduce the energy costs for that
building themselves so there you know
the heating and the cooling aspects of
this are very interesting and depending
on what climate zone you are you might
be going more towards the air
conditioning reduction through shading
or if you're in a northern community can
you derive benefit from planting
strategic plantings that are going to
reduce your eating and so the answer is
yes but you have to really think about
that and design that as such also
there's a credit which developed and is
obviously very important depending on
the area that you're living in and the
landscape that you're developing to
strategically plans to reduce the risk
of catastrophic wildfires so something
that's really important that West and so
we worked with forest forest service
guidelines from the west coast
and there's already quite a lot of data
on strategically planting or not
planting things in some click cases
close to or around your sites in order
to reduce the risk of complete
devastation by wildfires also
controlling and retaining your
construction pollutants this is
something similarly to the maintaining
your vegetation and soil protection
zones during the construction process
this is a prerequisite as well you
actually have no choice but to do this
thank goodness because sometimes during
your construction process construction
pollutants or other pollutants can can
create a lot of havoc and so erosion is
also a big part of this consideration so
you have to prove that you're not
creating a worse situation through your
construction process through through
this rain water management as well so
we're also looking to Stewart different
kinds of management of precipitation on
the site and improving your runoff
volume and water quality in general and
so a lot of sites have really taken this
to heart in the pilot projects at least
and have gone on to do a lot of great
water management strategies so this is
just an example obviously these are rain
gardens and bioswales and a parking lot
to control runoff there so now I'm going
to go into some actual pilot project
examples and show you some of what's
come to fruition over the last couple of
years through the the testing and
refinement of the process so this is
hunts point landing which is in the
Bronx in New York and so this is the
before and it's not very pretty this is
even further to the water so you can see
here it's a highly degraded landscape
and yeah I guess you know you've got a
couple people who are able to fish there
but in general this is not very a very
high quality site so luckily the they
were able to get a much better design
and implemented here
and has anybody ever been to this site
no okay well anyway you can see here
that they've installed a whole wonderful
landscape here ended up it's become a
major public amenities they still I
think allow the fishing to continue so
they saw that as a positive on the site
already that people were using it as
such so it's it's just it's a much nicer
area now overall and obviously a lot of
sites in the Bronx as you know are
highly degraded and would be considered
brownfield so I think this was also in
that category so extra points are
awarded for those who choose to take on
a brownfield site and to remediate it
and to create a beautiful landscape on
those sites because those can be
particularly challenging and expensive
to to manage so these are the points of
breakdown of what this particular pilot
project was able to achieve so you can
see here because it was a brownfield
they got the maximum amount of points 21
points for their site selection just by
selecting the brownfield they were off
to a good start then they all also got
for four out of four points for
pre-design assessment and planning some
pretty good water stewardship points
soil and vegetation you know about fifty
fifty percent there but still pretty
good material selection they didn't get
anything so I'm not sure what went on
there but maybe that just wasn't the
priority of the project but it's
interesting to see how you could still
achieve certification without
necessarily having to go into all of the
credits human health and well-being
because they kept this to be a good
public amenity and it was still a public
site they were able to prove value their
construction process obviously was
pretty well managed and they're still
monitoring it and we're able to also get
some innovation points so so this is
just a good example and then now here's
how it looks today so another great
example of is washington canal park and
so this is was a highly degraded site in
middle of Washington DC it used to be a
bus depot as you can see there and when
you take the above view you can see that
it was obviously surrounded in you know
by dense plant dense not planting dense
buildings and that this site was going
to likely be a challenge to develop as a
sustainable site but they came up with
some fantastic solutions to manage this
site from here on in with all rainwater
and stormwater harvested water supplies
so this is a graphic that might be a
little far away for you to see in detail
but essentially they're collecting
rainwater from all the buildings around
this courtyard area and directing the
storm water underground and cleaning the
water so that it's using this water in
all different ways on the site so here's
some examples of their of their rain
gardens and and then their collection
mechanisms here which are relatively
simple but then they go underground and
recirculate and then they actually even
have so essentially rainwater harvested
open sort of publicly accessible
fountains which if anybody works in when
regulations at all this is really
difficult to get through the regulatory
bodies because for many many years
there's been a big fear of not having
traditional treated potable water in all
your water features for that are
publicly accessible so this is a fight
they fought the good fight here and they
won because they were able to prove that
they could take storm water and take
rain water and clean it to the point
where they could have it be you know of
a high enough quality to have children
playing with it so that's really
tremendous and so kudos to them this is
really a fabulous project not just for
that reason but that is
amazing thing that they were able to do
so I think luckily they were probably
able to connect with the u.s. botanic
garden which is a site close by that was
a major developer of this entire system
and probably get them on board to help
get the decision makers to make sure
that this was ezel to happen so also no
I can't forget to mention the cornell
university's man library entrance which
is a pilot project that was completed in
2012 and it was planted I know through
Nina's class now I can't do I can't
remember the name of the class is it
urban urban Eden that's right ok so it
was planted through and planned through
the urban Eden class and so they were
able to achieve a one-star rating so one
star is absolutely better than no stars
so fantastic that they were able to do
this and this was also a testing case
for a really small site this site is not
that large it's really essentially the
the planting areas right in front of the
landscape so not the whole quad and
they've also been doing tremendous work
because there are testing the soil over
time and they're feeding the data back
on some of the soil remediation work
that was done in this particular area
back into the site's sort of data
collection process so they they used a
scoop and dump technique to remediate
the soil which had been heavily impacted
by construction so it was basically I
think used in part is a parking lot for
some of the construction practices or
maybe a staging area and some air in
some in some respects so all of that can
really negatively impact the soil and so
they have a control as well they have an
area of comparative I guess soil quality
from the time when they started that
they're leaving as a control too and so
they're comparing and contrasting how
the soil quality is improving over time
and I believe they're using the healthy
Cornell healthy soils test protocols for
that is anybody familiar with that here
yeah so that's that's how they're going
through and so primarily this particular
pilot project was a lot about soil
quality and and planting and what what
results you can
over time from that for making
adjustments so I mentioned before that
there's 200 points total for
certification so they're moving more
into the sites certified so baseline or
silver gold and platinum and anything
over 135 points is considered platinum
level or above and the Green Building
Council now taking on the certification
fully I think it's still actually a
little bit in development so since the
announcement of the certification
process moving into Green Building
Council status it's still pretty early
on they're still coming together and
finalizing that so if you're interested
in registering a site as a sustainable
site you should probably contact the
sustainable sites people first and you
can actually get registered you can get
on your way with it and of course you
can always use the guidelines the
guidelines you don't have to register
and certify the project to use the
guidelines you just kind of have to have
the book or downloaded so and we always
encourage anybody to use them we don't
have to go through full certification
even any small component of this has got
a lot of great material in it so we
encourage that but how it all fits
together long term is GBC I does the
credentialing and so they're actually a
separate nonprofit from the US Green
Building Council and they set this up
deliberately so that the US and Building
Council's lead system wasn't getting
vetted and certified by itself so they
thought in order to avoid the conflict
they have a separate body the GBC I
group that does the actual
certifications of the projects but the
US Green Building Council is the one
responsible for professional development
education and so stewardship of the
overall system and so that's really the
way it's going to work but in
partnership with the sustainable sites
team that works out of Lady Bird Johnson
Wildflower Center in Texas of course so
that's mushing together now and is well
on its way to full accreditation what's
likely to come in a year or two is
professional credentialing so is there
anybody here who is certified as a lead
professional know maybe mutt that's
generally more landscape architecture
credential but you can be professionally
certified and credentialed to be a lead
professional and there's various levels
of lead professional credentialing so
the thought is that you could also be
certified as a professional sites on
professional sites and I'm not sure
exactly what they're going to call that
but that's likely coming in 2017 so
worth mentioning also is landscape for
life which is a somewhat lighter version
of the sustainable sites initiative
that's being stewarded through the u.s.
Botanic Garden primarily and its really
an educational program that I it helps
homeowners and folks who aren't really
in the in the landscape perfection
better understand sustainable sites
there's a lot of heavy data and
information and and work in the
sustainable sites reference guide that
is far beyond what your average home
owner or somebody who's not going to
delve that deeply into it really wants
to get into so sustainable sites is for
a professional this is really for
anybody including general
decision-makers who don't really need to
know all the nitty-gritty details about
it but it gives a lot of the underlying
principles that are also in sustainable
sites but takes them to a pretty basic
level and so there's a whole education
program that us botanic garden works
through here so you can get a free
online training or even in course
training and there's a little bit of a
train-the-trainer component as well so
this is also a great project for folks
who are in community horticulture and we
need be horticultural stewardship so
it's worth checking out you can go on
their website and download a lot of
great materials and connect with them if
you're interested and so with that I
will thank you and I'd love to open up
for any questions Sonia
so the question is what do you do with
existing sites that you don't want to
fully renovate or completely gut and
redo and how to work on those yeah I
think that's a very good thing to think
about on the horizon so my prediction is
that similar to the way the lead system
has developed over time lead started
with new construction then it moved into
other types of systems that go far
beyond new construction including
existing buildings operations and
maintenance and lead for neighborhoods
which is at a whole different scale for
urban planning and so on and so forth so
I predict that sites could go in that
direction as well and so we've
definitely talked about that but
existing sites existing site operations
and maintenance is definitely a whole
different scene so but probably that
will come yeah it's just going to take
some time they're going to have to get
through the professional credentialing
first and then get make sure that the
new the new project the new project
system is well underway before they get
well that's a really good question too
so the follow up so I think one thing
that we hope through the development of
sites to do is to have follow-up and to
not just say All Right see you later
here's your certification and then you
could let it all go to pot in theory and
you would still have your site
certification that's something that we
really don't want to happen but the cost
to come back and keep checking on sites
over time is actually quite significant
so I should mention that there's
actually a flat rate pretty much right
now to be registered and to be going
through the certification process so
regardless of the size of your site at
this point it ranges between about
twenty five hundred dollars to like nine
thousand depending on how you're going
to go through certification and that's
just kind of like a flat fee and so in
order to be able to afford through the
management
system to be sending people back there
may have to be like an add on after the
fact so that you can kind of keep your
certification over time and I think what
the landscape side of it it really makes
sense to do that long-term and to try to
you know just keep checking up on it the
lead system from what I understand
doesn't really have that so once you get
your LEED Platinum certification there
there isn't at this point and they maybe
they're changing this a way to go back
and ensure that that particular building
that's been certified for new
construction is operating optimally or
still operating with all the principles
in place so it's an interesting
challenge well as I think with all of
these semi competitive systems like the
competitive nature and people is one
hopeful monk patient even though that
can sometimes come out of the negative
we want people to compete to be the most
sustainable in their landscape design
construction and maintenance so I think
that's definitely one factor that like
it or not you know we we tend to have
that is 11 motivation also anybody who's
gone through the pilot process and look
deeply at the system I think really
finds that they learn a lot too through
the process so hopefully that's one
motivation and just wanting to get on
track for sustainability long term is
something that I think is really
important to keep in mind as well also
I'm coming from a public garden
standpoint and a lot of public gardens
have figured out that they just need to
do this no matter what that we need to
be the leader so there's been a lot of
great leadership in the public garden
world already in working with
sustainable sites as i mentioned phipps
conservatory us botanic garden Lady Bird
Johnson Wildflower Center a lot of
public gardens have taken this on and
felt that they just have to do this to
maintain the brand that they have
because it's expected that we'd be
really top notch not only in our
landscapes in general and how beautiful
they look but also in all the underlying
sustainability
in the design and management of those
systems so it seems like easy for us
whether your typical privately managed
landscape or privately owned or
industrial landscape wants to go to this
I think it may be something about you
know brand management that they want to
push forward also and I know that I
think what Stuart it a lot of it would
lead our early stage and high-ranking
lead projects as well well so the
interesting thing is some of these
sections you actually can't ever get all
of them because it's almost like an
either/or so either you're doing if you
don't have certain site conditions you
just can't do it and so it's not that
you should be penalized for not doing it
and so that's the challenge with the
scoring system you might always feel
that if you don't get everything that
you're not doing the best but if they
you don't have a natural area you can't
get a credit for protecting natural
heirs because you just don't have one or
if you don't have a wetland on site
already you can't get a credit for
predicting an existing wetland so
there's several credits like that that
are really optional and so it's not
designed that you can get all of them so
so that's partially the problem or it's
not really a problem it's just the way
it is yeah in the town just east of here
we have don't even in sin
lead antenna like to see just added to
that the problem we run into is that
because it's a qualitative is the
assignment a point to somewhat
qualitative we find we have proposals
that are offering very different
ecosystem service levels but they both
qualify for getting the incentive so
that is a constant problem trying to to
make sure the rating system matches the
benefit that they're actually bringing
yeah oh it's it's very very big and deep
and wide challenge I don't know any
other way to say it's there's a lot to
think about here and trying to Stewart a
holistic system and to think about all
the different parameters and all the
different ways that we could be
quantifying and calculating properly is
really it's really challenging but it's
a lot of fun thank goodness like it is
fun to I should have mentioned that
that's kind of my motivation it's like
all right I'm gonna I'm going to you
know hurt my brain a lot doing this but
it's but it's for the best hopefully
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu